so this is super interesting as a
standalone like the fact that we are now
going to have a Black Friday football
game on Thanksgiving weekend and people
like myself are super fired up there's a
much bigger more important macro thing
here that's Brewing that I think is
going to really dominate the next decade
this game is being played during a
massive retail day the biggest retail
Day by the biggest retail platform on
the internet
if you look at what tick tock's doing
with buying up warehouses and you look
at what happens in China with live
shopping and the full stack I think the
next decade is going to be defined by
this concept of content and commerce
mixing together influencer affiliate
programs the Walmarts the Kroger
Albertsons M A the Amazons and then the
social platforms like Facebook and
others actually buying retail companies
are getting deeper into retail
content and commerce are in a crash
course and it's going to change the
economic landscape of the next decade